c'est une tradition qui s'enracine et
c'est tant mieux le 12 ou la littérature
québécoise est à l'honneur les libraires
encourage donc les lecteurs et lectrices
à acheter local
on profite de cette occasion pour parler
littérature avec dany laferrière on va
quand même pas bouder ce plaisir bonsoir
dany laferrière oui bonsoir mais plutôt
par les librairies
oui mais c'est ça la littérature en plus
en plus on peut la lire dans n'importe
quelle condition à n'importe quelle
situation
mais j'étais à montréal après ma saison
en france et à la câline française et je
me disais comment va la librairie et au
québec
comment va la librairie à montréal parce
que avec le la pandémie et on se dit
personne ne peut se déplacer
comment font les libraires et la
meilleure façon c'est d'aller voir
oui c'est d'aller voir pascal expérience
elle est unique pour pourquoi ce vous
croyez on devrait valoriser davantage
cette habitude de bouquiner de consulter
son libraire d'entamer un dialogue de
découvrir de voyager dans une librairie
mais c'est ce que j'étais faire j'ai
visité 12 librairies indépendantes et
une librairie de renaud bray je suis
allé par moi même et de façon très
simple et très aisée et j'ai pris une
petite caméra et on est allé à la
librairie la librairie du square c'est
la première librairie se trouve en face
du café servi et c'est la librairie j'ai
publié mon premier livre c'est
l'allégorie qui a exposé le la première
qui a exposé mon premier livre comment
faire l'amour avec un [ __ ] sans se
fatiguer je passais et je suis rentré
dans cette librairie et le libre
également reçu avec avec cette joie cet
enthousiasme que je vais retrouver dans
toutes les autres librairies l'abri
j'étais étonné je pensais que la
librairie était à genoux il m'a dit tout
de suite non ça va bien ça va bien c'est
à dire ça va pas il ya quand même le
virus mère ça va bien on s'attendait pas
à ce que les lecteurs soient encore
intéressé à ce point a retrouvé la
librairie a acheté à faire des
cueillettes
mais c'est dire à quel point dans un
contexte comme le contexte actuel celui
d'une pandémie
on recherche la littérature on recherche
aussi la libre
comme un refuge en quelque sorte au
sabre et verizon on recherche le
libraire c'est le libraire c'est pas le
fait de l'internet va pas remplacer et
le libre et à la chaleur humaine et des
gens qui s'avancent vers vous dès que
vous franchissez la porte jeune j'en ai
visité beaucoup je suis pas seulement
aller au carré saint louis je suis allé
dans une petite librairie dans le
quartier hochelaga et qui s'appelle la
livre e ri parce qu'un des enfants des
trois jeunes femmes libraire lui avait
dit mi-août une boulangère ça fait
vibrer ça fait une livre y est j'ai
trouvé cette ambiance de pionnière et
parce que la vieille librairie du
quartier douche à la ga et le chercher
des trésors ayant fait faillite
il fallait une nouvelle et ces jeunes
femmes se sont mises et pour faire cette
librairie de gauche féministe activiste
vivant partisane une hybride heureuse
brillante même si l'on peut dire
je suis allé dans d'autres librairies où
l'on ne va pas généralement à la
librairie dan cratère lit dans un cadre
lycées c'est dans le quartier c'est
urbain c'est sur la rue bernard vue et
cette librairie et est divisé en deux
c'est sa particularité il y a eu ni
brillant face qui s'occupe des enfants
grande salle bien éclairé pour les
enfants très vaste et une autre très
très coloré et qui est leur librairie
disons général on trouve beaucoup de
livres d'engrais naturellement mais
beaucoup aussi en français dont je suis
pas resté là je suis allé à mascouche
il y à la librairie lulu et 7 à visiter
parce que là il se trouve une jeune
femme qui vient de gaspésie qui est
libre et elle s'appelle unis sir est
bien joli cyr a été entraîné à ce goût
de lire par sa grand-mère qui misait des
romans à l'eau de rose en gaspésie et
pendant qu'elle visait elle et des
livres de la courte échelle
alors on les voit il faut les imaginer
toute petite elle lisait à côté de sa
grand-mère et c'est comme ça qu'elle est
rentré à montréal elle est devenue
libraire dans cette magnifique petite
librairie à mascouche
je suis allé aussi à la librairie
carcajou et carcajou c'est une grande
librairie l'hallali spacey et fast est
une ennemie bien installé dans un centre
d'achat et et cette librairie la hune
libre est aussi qui est extrêmement
compétente c'est-à-dire aussi j'ai été
impressionné par là
compétences et des libraires je n'ai pas
été étonné savait mais j'étais et
pression' et parce que là j'étais tout
seul avec eux et ils me racontaient les
livres et aussi leur goût de défendre
des livres qui ne sont pas forcément des
best-sellers de livres de poésie
exactement
oui mais voilà vous mentionner les
enfants la jeunesse c'est essentiel de
le dire surtout dans un contexte où les
enfants ont été privés d'école à
montréal pendant près de six mois
alors c'est là où la librairie devient
essentiel en première ligne du combat si
on veut dans le contexte actuel pour
satisfaire ce vice impuni qu'est la
lecture vous l'avez suivi alors en quoi
la pandémie change quelque chose dans
notre rapport à la littérature et vous
comme écrivain est ce que ça vous
inspire davantage qui se passe et du
sonos tout ce qui se passe même inspiré
et l'écrivain de ces spire pas forcément
de l'actualité ou là cette actualité
prend du temps avant de lui parvenir
avant d'atteindre son émotion
mais je suis aussi quelqu'un de la vie
quotidienne je suis d'abord électeurs je
suis d'abord électeurs et je suis
sensible aux liens que fait la
littérature entre les humains et c'est
ça la librairie c'est un chaînon chaînon
qui ne peut pas être on peut pas faire
et basse on ne peut pas c'est
incontournable la librairie parce que il
y à l'individu la personne humaine et ça
c'est extrêmement important et quand un
libraire est compétent et qui s'avance
vers vous et qui sait de quoi il va
parler
et comme par exemple à renaud bray ou ou
le libraire qui m'a reçu et il est pris
mais émile les migrants de poésie et
qu'il me parle de sa section de poésie
et qui là qu'il a monté une très jolie
section où les poètes ils veulent pas
beaucoup donc il faut des libraires
passionnés et pour trouver les lecteurs
de poésie au moins et qui existe je suis
allé aussi à la librairie à lire et à
longueuil où tout le monde connaît manon
trépanier et qui a longtemps été
chroniqueuse et de la libre
les francophones et cette émission que
les amateurs littérature connaissent et
qui relie la france et la belgique la
suisse et le québec et pour pour une il
faut une émission sur les livres dont un
autre panier avec sa vivacité son
enthousiasme et c'est ça la pousse des
libraires et c'est un enthousiasme qui
est important notamment comme vecteur
pour alimenter des gens quant à la
littérature québécoise c'est là où elle
est présente dans les librairies
indépendantes à l'avantagé des créatures
québécoise qui a besoin des lecteurs
absolument qui a besoin la littérature
québécoise a besoin pas de béquille a
besoin même pas d'être soutenus d'être
indiqué parce que on soutient quelque
chose qui ne peut pas y est allé tout
seul
la littérature québécoise peut marcher l
essentiel ça va bien vous qui voyez
l'ensemble de la production littéraire à
l'échelle de la francophonie qu'avez
vous à dire sur la littérature
québécoise le diagnostic en fait elle
est excellente
moi je vais dans beaucoup de festivals
dans le monde pas forcément dans la
francophonie et je vois par exemple le
salon du livre de montréal c'est cette
extraordinaire et la littérature le
nombre de librairies il faut dire que
non tout le milieu culturel québécois et
peut-être nous nous devons protesté vous
faut garder ce milieu encore plus vivant
mais à comparer c'est extraordinaire ce
qui se passe
le nombre de nids qui se publie on
retient on tient la route et nos libre
et à la variété mais des émissions on va
dire dany dit kylie alors de moins en
moins d'émissions littéraires mais même
moi quand je vais en italie je suis
impressionné négativement par le nombre
d'émissions de radio dire que la radio
nationale et il y à des pays très très
puissant très grands où l'on est étonné
de voir que le milieu culturel qui
m'épate c'est la route mais finalement
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut fermer
les yeux
mais il faut quand même avouer prendre
ce jour ce dozos qui est la fête du
livre un endroit pour le dire au pot ce
et pourront reconnaître que aval qui a
été fait et célébrer cette belle
et ratures vous qui faites partie de
cette offre en et en attendant avec
impatience votre prochain ouvrage peu
importe la forme que ça prendra aussi
que décèle une place important de
ferrières mais aussi l'immortel merci
pour cet entretien
je n'oublie pas hommelibre pardon merci
non je parlais d'une dernière librairie
zone libre j'ai été oui à zone libre qui
est magnifique et qui est né de deux en
lutte
on se souvient que ce groupuscule
politique d'extrême mecque et c'est une
des rallyes bosio l'eau peut encore
trouver et le livre de de karl marx
hexagone gay mais aussi la littérature
générale tant de belles librairie à la
grandeur du québec merci beaucoup
d'années à faire et à merci aux piles oh
merci et au revoir